du haut de ses 10 ans s'éloigne Jaxon
c'est déjà faire des salto arrière sans
aucune difficulté rien de sûr rien de
surprenant quand on sait qu'il pratique
le freerun un sport qui consiste à
franchir rapidement des obstacles
urbains ou naturels sans l'aide de
matériel mais en faisant des figures
impressionnantes nous sommes allés le
rencontrer dans la salle où il
s'entraîne avec son coach un ancien
finaliste de Ninja Warrior reportage de
Clémence dosc
[Musique]
à tout juste 10 ans si Louane s'entraîne
plusieurs fois par semaine sa discipline
le freerun là où le parcours vise la
vitesse et l'efficacité ce sport met
l'accent sur la créativité et
l'esthétique des acrobaties une passion
venue suite au confinement après
l'inscription du jeune garçon à une
salle dédiée il y a pas une compétition
entre tous ces jeunes là il y a vraiment
juste ah mais attends là tu l'as vas-y
essaye comme ça bah tu sais que si tu
passes ça tu peux passer ça et donc ça
ça c'est hyper joli et je vois qu'il y a
plus d'âge en fait il y a plus de notion
d'âge quand il parle de leur truc qu'ils
aient dit sous vingt ans c'est la même
chose et ça je trouve ça hyper joli
l'absence de compétition entre les
adeptes n'atténue pas le perfectionnisme
de siloine persévérant il répète ses
enchaînements
c'est une figure
[Musique]
on met le ventre sur un module comme ça
et avec les jambes on va les monter
jusqu'à là à peu près et fouetter le
plus fort possible pour envoyer la
rotation arrière
le freerun se pratique aussi bien en
intérieur qu'en extérieur ses parents
documentent ces progrès via les réseaux
sociaux une manière de se faire
connaître auprès de la communauté
le jeune sportif apprend aux côtés des
meilleurs son coach ancien finaliste de
l'émission ninja Warriors voit en lui
beaucoup de potentiels
comme il fait avec passion et
persévérance clairement il peut aller il
peut aller très très loin il a que 10
ans à cet âge-là clairement on n'a pas
le niveau qu'il a normalement donc déjà
il a un très très beau gros talent et en
plus il s'en il s'acharne à
l'entraînement pas de compétition pour
siloine la pratique reste un moment de
plaisir de quoi peaufiner ses
enchaînements pour cette éternelle
insatisfait